hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is time for the monday morning
podcast for monday
august 23rd
2021 what's going on how are ya
how's it go i love saying hawaii i
always say how are you but you know
after 10 days in massachusetts it it it
warms my heart
oh my god i'm back in l.a
which i'm not gonna lie to you
all right
when we were on uh you know
the little [ __ ]
the last little part of the flight
whatever you call that our approach into
lax
and i looked out the window and i just
saw the [ __ ]
you know smoke from the fires from god
knows where
i was like jesus christ
what did i just leave what did i move to
you know
if i just had more of a normal childhood
i could have just stayed you know what
but i would have stayed there and i
wouldn't have appreciated it
that's the thing right now you think
people living in wakefield understand
how great their life people up in
marblehead they don't
know they don't know
they've just always been there
okay
they're red chest and they're even
browner freckles every year on their
chest
right above their cleavage man boobs are
titties whatever your [ __ ] preference
right they don't know
walking around in boat shoes
getting their umpteen [ __ ] lobster
roll not questioning
not questioning why in 2021 we still
have to boil those poor crustaceans
alive that's why i won't i don't [ __ ]
with lobster
i don't [ __ ] with veal
you know and i bet if i looked into kobe
beef i wouldn't [ __ ] with that either
i don't [ __ ] with shampoo because i'm
bald
not cause what they do to the rabbits
what do you think a rabbit says to god
when it dies
you know like what what the [ __ ] was
that god
you know i love that we're so arrogant
as human beings we don't everybo every
one of us
gets a conversation with god
after we die
he sits down and takes out his giant the
giant manila envelope photo
of your [ __ ] life and is gonna sit
down and go blow by blow of all the good
[ __ ] and all the bad [ __ ] like
let me ask you this
if you were god and you had the ability
the [ __ ]
ability
to create the universe
to create whatever you want to create
are you going to waste your time with
all of that paperwork
one of the umpteen thousand [ __ ]
earths out there right
this is the one he pays attention to and
he just can't wait to take me to task
about 1986 when i blabber blue
right
let's say he does
let's say he's got that kind of [ __ ]
time
i mean how long does it take to review
somebody's life he's got to be blowing
through this [ __ ]
that's kind of uplifting i would think
even if you go to hell after you die the
the [ __ ] waiting time has got to be
ridiculous
you know it's like trying to get packers
green bay green bay packers season
tickets back in the day i don't know
about now
i don't know if you can get them now i
have no idea
i have no idea and is that a statement
of the loyalty
of the fans in and around appleton
wisconsin or is that more a statement of
there's just nothing to [ __ ] do out
here
i don't give a [ __ ] if lynn dickey's the
quarterback okay
i'm on a waiting list for season tickets
waiting for our next bot stop
bart starr the last hall of famer to
wear 15 at quarterback in the nfl it has
been an over 50-year [ __ ] drought
and along comes patrick mahomes
patrick mahomey um
he comes along
and what does he do
what does he do
he puts number 15 back on the map
that quarterback no kid grew up wanting
to be number 15 nobody did
15 is a slow number
you know i think about when i think of
15 i think one one that joe theismann
helmet one [ __ ] bar across your face
mac
lining up to do a straight on field kick
missing half your foot that's what i
think of
i think of tom dempsey that's what i
think of you know what these kids today
they're gonna think of patrick of holmes
i can't say anything today patrick
holmes patrick mahomes that's who
they're gonna think of
they're gonna think of throwing a
no-look pass to their friend who's
looking back at him about ready to run
into a mailbox and then you know two
completes is a first right
you guys ever play that in the street
two completes in a row is a first
pass the telephone pole is a touchdown
um two-hand touch
in the street
anyway
so how [ __ ] arrogant are we of as
human beings that we think god's gonna
waste his [ __ ] time reviewing
everybody's stupid ass [ __ ]
life
i mean i would think you'd have to live
a life of some sort of significance
where you were the greatest [ __ ] dude
ever or the biggest piece of [ __ ] ever
all right and notice how i just talked
about that in male
terms
i have not even included women having
their life
reviewed
okay there's no way god's going to put
himself through that listen to their
[ __ ] whining and crying in their
argument he's just gonna let him in
he's just gonna let him in and when he
does does that really make it heaven for
men
i'm [ __ ] with you but anyway what
kind of a [ __ ] world do you
think that this person is going to take
the time to review your [ __ ] life
going to applebee's [ __ ] drinking in
the woods
whatever the [ __ ] you did he's going to
take his time to do that but but he's
not wasting his time with a rabbit a
rabbit dies it's just [ __ ] dead
and you know what i would say the only
reason why we believe that is because
you can't teach a rabbit how to unload a
truck
that's why so there's no need to control
those [ __ ] things and if anybody
deserves to be in the tsa pre-check line
into heaven i would say it would be a
bunny rabbit
all right
name something that can't [ __ ]
overpower that thing and kill it
sit around eating veggies man right
they're like little liberals hopping on
hopping all around the [ __ ] woods
with their stupid bunny tails out just
thinking of the best of people
you know
sure they could use some invisalign but
nobody's perfect right just go they're
just out there to be killed
hawks
snakes
coyotes
anything you can just get their [ __ ]
hands on them
people
who used to cut their feet off and stick
it in some tie-dye and walk around say
this is good luck
i don't know
this is all the [ __ ] that goes through
my [ __ ] head you know what i mean i
spend a lot of time by myself even when
i'm with people if you know what i mean
some of you know what i mean
do you have that ability to be sitting
there nodding doing active listening as
you're [ __ ] nine million miles away
in your head
you know
um
so anyway we're back here but i gotta be
honest with you it's nice to be back
here with all my stuff that i've
accumulated throughout the years i miss
my drums
bill you can ship your drums back east i
know i could um
and i've been playing a lot lately
having a great [ __ ] time
and uh
i actually came
across this triplet exercise i think i
was talking to you guys about this but
i've been sticking with it and my foot
has never been faster
it's never been more powerful it's never
been more upfront
in my dad drumming
and my dad never been in even in a
wedding band drumming that i do
um
very excited about that i've been coming
up with different like exercises myself
where i can then
do things to improve like the three in a
row
on the bass drum
where at that point the pivot point
becomes your ankle
you know and your foot's flopping like
you just blew out your achilles
that [ __ ]
so i'm just coming up with stuff you
know slowing it down and moving up and i
kind of really figured out why i wasn't
able to push through because you know
remember back in the day in the 80s
maybe the 80s people when you would
you'd bench in every two weeks you'd see
dude let's see what a max is
i do that every time i work on you
and what you know you saw what your max
was but then what you did was you backed
off 40 [ __ ] pounds
and you built that up so you could do 10
reps and then your max would increase i
don't do that
that's not how i drum i go all the way
up to my max and then try to [ __ ]
play at my max and then i [ __ ]
jack up my leg or my foot or something
like that
you know i gotta learn to take a step
back
you know i think that's something we
could all think about every once in a
while just taking a step back don't you
think
um
i'm actually bummed out that i missed
that tropical storm
that hit uh massachusetts right after i
left
you know my ego wants to say people were
that upset that i didn't spend 11 days
in massachusetts including mother nature
that that was mother nature crying
that my pasty thighs were not going to
be gracing the beaches
[Music]
of
massachusetts um
we were right on the water and dude
there's nothing better than that seeing
that being on the water and seeing some
[ __ ]
storm coming in
that's exciting [ __ ] seeing the power of
nature
right
watching some guy in a shiny [ __ ]
suit on your flat screen tv going a
tropical storm is just touching it's
like buddy i'm looking i'm looking at
what you're talking about
this is like interactive weather channel
type [ __ ] dude how smart was byron allen
byron allen in general how smart is that
guy
one of the people i looked up to in this
business
anytime i see a performer that somehow
figures out how to get on the other side
of the desk
you know
and and actually
do well on that side the business side
there's a bunch of people out there but
he's
he's uh he's on my mount rushmore people
that did that and that guy bought the
weather channel
i mean how brilliant is that
you know i mean there's so many of these
channels out there that they're just not
gonna [ __ ] last but the weather
channel with global warming
i mean i'm looking at like you're gonna
see like a will smith tom cruise movie
every [ __ ] six months pretty soon
with the kind of weather that we're
gonna be getting and you're just in
these [ __ ]
weather people on this channel whatever
you call them meteorologists
whether hey aren't you one of them
weather people
meteorologists
are going to become
superstars
they are going to be the walter
cronkites and the walter cronkettes
um
of the future
that's what we're all gonna be watching
is these meteorologists
just sitting there
taking off their [ __ ] glasses going i
don't think this
war with mother nature is winnable
it's no longer winnable um
i don't know how if global warming is
going to kill all of us you know i just
don't want to be washed out to sea
that's my thing
even if i'm immediately dead there's
just something about floating out there
and these little not even sharks just
those little [ __ ] things coming up
you know taking a nibble
[Music]
you know you'd have no pants on
like a sock some [ __ ] just [ __ ] ass
up and they [ __ ] getting sunburned
just floating there
waiting for nature to clean you up
clean up the whole memory of you
jesus that's dark
um
anyway
so here's something that i learned
going back east other than i can't
believe how much i miss massachusetts
and how lucky i was to grow up there
um
is i realize you know crocs you know
those ugly ass [ __ ] shoes that i
thought were made out of plastic they're
actually made out of rubber
i believe i think that's rubber i don't
know what it is maybe it's some sort of
man-made
[ __ ] i have no idea
um
but they can actually shrink if you
leave them in the sun
and i shrunk my [ __ ] crocs
you know and the only way to get them
back is you got to stick them in a
boiling pot of water
for a minute
and then take it out and immediately
stick your foot in it if you can [ __ ]
handle it
to try to get him to stretch back out
again but even then they're never the
same
they're never the same
you know
it's like mystic river
was the last time you saw that dude was
the last time i saw him
in the back seat of that car back in
1974 that's where my crocs were they
were in the back of that [ __ ] car
on that little shelf where if you had
like four kids that kid laid across that
one with no seat belt on that's where
they were sitting
driving off with some [ __ ] pervert
creep uh
priest um
yeah so my wife was upset because they
were a gift that she got me because
everybody else has crocs and i did not
want them i'm like i'm not wearing those
stupid [ __ ] things i don't want them
i have plenty of footwear i don't need
them so you know
you know women are they always listen to
you right
she goes out and she buys them anyways
so then she buys me these things that i
didn't want because now everybody has
them and it gives you know a cute sense
of family which i understand
all right
but i did say i didn't want them
you know i could go out and buy
everybody a [ __ ] patriots hat my wife
doesn't want to wear it
do i get sad
i don't
just thought i needed to answer that for
you i don't get sad i just i underst i
go oh you don't like sports why would i
force that upon you
um some reason doesn't work the other
way
would you like a pair of crocs no i
would not why
right there
right there you know you're getting
crocs
why
i i don't know
i'm just asking
you don't have to get upset
um
i got one for you guys i have a thing
that's probably not it's gonna get me in
trouble
this is for all the guys out there of
course
i have a game that i would like you guys
to participate in
all right
this is what you do you
you take your cell phone camera and you
get it ready
and when your wife has her back to you
ask her to do something for you
and when she turns around take a picture
of her face
dude i gotta tell you i gotta get nia on
this
the [ __ ] look
on my wife's face when like twice a
month i ask you to do something she just
stops in her tracks and she literally
looks at me
i can't even describe it's like this
it's almost like
confusion and concern
like she can't even understand the
question and then she has concern like
have i lost my mind
did i forget what the chain of command
is you you don't ask me to do i tell you
the things to do
they're like mr white i am the one who
knocks
so my wife has this [ __ ] i i do it now i
i have to wait because now she knows i'm
doing it i gotta wait every two weeks i
[ __ ]
i ask her to do something for me
i'll say can you do me a favor can you
go in the kitchen and get me a glass of
water
and i'm telling you it's like it's dead
in her trash she has this it's like
she just stares at me but i can't keep a
straight face anymore
um
can you guys do that just ask your wife
to do something for you and then [ __ ]
just
take a picture
take a picture of her face
i just want to see if i'm not alone in
this that's all
i'm also an [ __ ] so
you know
ladies you can have fun i'm sure you'll
steal the idea and then call yourself
brave and you'll do something else i
don't know what it is
um
anyway
huge huge huge huge
[ __ ] moment
as a father
on friday
this past friday my daughter officially
knows how to swim
um
you know i got to give a shout out to my
brother-in-law former lifeguard that
basically got her there and she was
right ready to do it and then the
pandemic hit
and then she didn't swim for a while and
then kind of got afraid of the water
again so um
he deserves like 99 of the credit so
i basically um
i was trying to explain to her how to do
the doggy paddle
and uh she just you know wasn't grasping
it so what i finally did was i said
listen just do the doggy paddle and i'll
just have my hand
under under your uh
your stomach right and all i did was
just do like
like index middle and thumb
so it's mainly her
and then what i'd do is she was going
along i could paddle faster powder
faster i would just take it away
and then she'd start to sink but she
would paddle faster and get her head up
and then start to sink for real then i
would just hold her back up again
and i did that for like five minutes in
next you know she was swimming by
herself it's [ __ ] amazing
now i'm not saying that's going to work
for you and obviously my brother-in-law
did a ton of work with her so i'm not
taking credit but i was there when it
happened and i saw the look of how
psyched and proud she was and um
that's a huge like relief for me as a
parent that my kid knows how to swim
that's a scary thing
when you get like you just look at your
kids like they don't know how to swim
uh hey you want to go out on a little
boat ride no i don't why my kids don't
know how to swim and i have two when i
can only get to one one at a time no
[ __ ] thank you not happening not
happening
um
anyway so that happened and my daughter
is also
like really into skateboarding now
she's been watching these videos and uh
she wants a skateboard so
she told me the skateboard she wanted it
has like a cartoon character on it and i
saw it the [ __ ] board was like 21
bucks
okay and i
the reason why i don't skateboard is
because i had a 21 skateboard the
equivalent of it in the 70s and your
feet hung off on either side and if you
hit a pebble you went flying like you
got ejected through the windshield of a
car
and they didn't have
pads when i was a kid they just did
he just [ __ ] went down
pads were wearing dungarees that's what
it was in a long-sleeve shirt that's
what pads were when i was a kid nobody
had [ __ ] pads nobody wore helmets it
was stupid
it was [ __ ] stupid and kids were
breaking their arms and their legs right
there was always some kid on crutches
just always happened fans didn't have
guards and people
[ __ ] fan blades were made out of
metal people chopped the tip of their
fingers i was [ __ ] nuts
it was [ __ ] nuts
um
so anyway i want to ask uh skateboard
people out here in la i want to get my
daughter into this sport
she's absolutely obsessed with it
she loves it she's starting to know the
names of the tricks and i think it's so
[ __ ] cool
i i i i gotta i gotta hook her up here
so
my question to you is where should i go
what size deck i believe you call it
should i get
uh what's a good starter board where
she's not gonna get hurt or whatever
i mean i know she's gonna get her cause
she's doing it but like you know i'm
gonna get her all the pads and
everything
but uh
where should i go i've already googled
and i saw the original
skateboard shop out here la skate
company
and then a few others or whatever and it
just seems like uh i don't know i don't
know anything about it
anything about it other than my daughter
is obsessed with it and she knows how to
ride a bike she can swim now let's let's
[ __ ] let's do skateboarding all of
this builds up confidence all of it
builds up self-esteem
right
then you teach him a little jujitsu they
can choke out a freak and what you got
is a complete [ __ ] person who will
now walk up to what she wants in life
you know
and find love and hopefully you know
there's a world for her when she gets
older and it's not 130 degrees up um so
if you guys have any information on that
i would greatly appreciate it and then
i'm going to pass it on
because already one of her relatives
wants to be the one that gets her the
skateboard so i just got to give him
the information um
so i've been watching a bunch of red sox
hoping that we were going to be crushing
the the bottom feeders of the league um
we're playing the ranges
and
we won the game um what
sale pitched
he did the usual i think i already
talked about this didn't i i can't
remember
um
but we lost last night and uh i guess
i'm finding out from people who watched
them all year the deal was they knew
sale wasn't coming back until the end of
the year and that's why they didn't make
a move and this the rest of the year is
sort of his rehab
and uh next year we're gonna make a push
where we're gonna go sign some big free
agency arm because that's what you do
now you go out and you buy a title so i
guess that that's what they're gonna do
i don't [ __ ] know i don't pretend to
know but i will tell you this i do
like
love baseball so much that i can even if
they get completely out of the race
which they're not
um no one can watch a meaningless
baseball game like myself i [ __ ]
i'll sit there all day and watch it and
uh and also i've been watching all the
untouchables
highly highly highly recommend that
series dude robert stack's character
says some of the coldest [ __ ] ever
i saw this episode right
this gangster is beaten to death and his
wife has to come in and identify the
body
of her dead husband and she comes in
they pull back the sheet his face is so
pulverized they don't show it but
they kind of let you know that's what is
his face is so pulverized she can't tell
who it is and they go well did he have
any identify any
marks or tattoos or scars she's like no
then she's like oh wait yes he had a
sort of a v-shaped scar
on his back right shoulder from a bullet
wound
and they rolled him over and she saw the
v-shaped scar and she just started
bawling crying right
so anyway you watch the rest of the
episode turns out
that was all an act
because that wasn't her husband and she
knew that it wasn't her husband it's a
long convoluted story as to why they
needed somebody else to pretend they
were dead when they really weren't right
they were blackmailing somebody
and they were keeping one guy alive so
then they could have power over this guy
so in the end of the episode robert
stack
faces off
with this woman's husband
who's actually really alive they have a
gun battle robert stack blows the guy
away
right in front of his wife
and his wife starts bawling again and
robert stack after killing her husband
right in front of her just looks at her
and says
real tears taste different don't they
mrs cagle
[Music]
i was like god damn
robert stack
there's elliot ness man
it's one of my favorite joe barnick told
me for years to watch it told me how
great it was it is [ __ ] amazing
there's only been out of all the
episodes at this point i've watched like
50 episodes there's only been one one
where they went too romantic and they
had string music and everything didn't
even make any sense for it to even be in
there
it'd be like having that scene in a
[ __ ] romantic comedy which just kind
of got outside themselves other than
that it was [ __ ] great and i got to
tell you frank sutton
who played sergeant carter in gomer pyle
is in two episodes that i've seen so far
playing two different characters because
back then you could do that [ __ ]
and he absolutely crushes it i have such
a ridiculous amount of respect for that
guy as an actor he's [ __ ] amazing
so um you know as funny as he was
on the gomer pyle series he was an
incredible dramatic actor um
all right and with that let's do a
little bit let's do a little bit of the
advertising here as i'm running my
[ __ ] yap
26 minutes in jesus bill come up for
real
all right look who oh look who it is
it's butcher box everybody
i love butcher box
soak up the last moments of summer with
butcher bucks maybe you're getting
together with your friends and families
you haven't seen them forever
or spending time doing what you missed
out doing on last year no matter what
you're doing the last thing you should
stress about is cooking sorry i thought
i was going to read this better than i
am options like 100 grass-fed and
grass-finished beef free-range organic
chicken humanely raised pork
not like those other pigs they're
getting slapped around out there in
tennessee
wild-caught lobster tails wild-caught
alaskan salmon you got no idea what
those crustaceans and fish are gonna do
and sugar slash
nitrate free bacon
i wouldn't mind a little sugar on my
bacon
sounds oddly perverted doesn't it
butcher box is a no-brainer each box has
9 to 11 pounds of meat which is packed
fresh shipped frozen and vacuum sealed
making it simple to store in the freezer
and pull a delicious meal together with
friends
luckily today's sponsor butcher box
wants you to celebrate the rest of the
summer right
dude there's nothing better than having
a freezer full of meat everything sounds
perverted on this reed
you know pandemic comes oh my god what
are we gonna do how about some [ __ ]
lobster straight tails or some humanely
raised pork
each one of those pigs were told that
they were loved before they blew their
brains out treat yourself receive a
special offer from butcher box when new
members sign up butcher box will gift
you free chicken
burgers and hot dogs in your first box i
mean come on
this deal is great for sharing or
enjoying by yourself and it's a great
it's a great trolling gift to give to
one of your vegan friends there is
enough variety to satisfy everyone's
preferences the process is simple
number one
once you signed up you choose your box
and delivery frequency they offer five
different boxes four curated box options
as well as the popular custom box if you
don't mind i would like to select my own
lines of meat
so you can get exactly what you want and
your and your what you and your family
love sorry butcher box ships your order
frozen
at the peak of freshness right after
they whack that [ __ ] pig they shove
it right in the freezer packed in an
eco-friendly 100
recyclable box
you're you enjoy great tasting high
quality meat delivered right to your
door free shipping butcher box wants you
to enjoy the rest of the summer with
this special meal so here we go so here
we go butcher box is giving our
listeners a special offer of three
pounds of chicken breast two pounds of
burgers and one pack of hot dogs for
free
right now new members can get this
special deal deal when they sign up at
butcherbox.com
burr that's butcherbox.com
for free chicken burgers and hot dogs in
your first box just know that there's
probably somebody in ethiopia right now
listening to this going what the [ __ ]
are these americans waiting for
sign up for that [ __ ]
um i hope they're not still starving
over ethiopia that makes no [ __ ]
sense does it
you know i mean
it really doesn't make any [ __ ] al
all of the pain and suffering so much of
it just doesn't make sense until you
look at how people make money
um policy genius everybody to properly
provide for their families most people
need 10 times the life insurance cover
coverage
that they get through their employer
those cheap bastards
policy gene yeah because you know what
once you die they want all your [ __ ]
orphans to come work for them
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place why compare
well why wouldn't you you dumb bastard
you can save up to 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius
you know you don't just accept the first
offer that comes down the pike i mean
that's business 101.
you could save 1300 or more per year on
life insurance by using policy genius to
compare policies the licensed experts at
policy genius you know who they work for
they work for you
not the insurance company so you can
trust them to help you navigate every
step of the shopping and buying process
getting started is easy
it's like heroin it's easy to start hard
to stop first head to policygenius.com
minutes you can work out how much life
insurance coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and scheduling for free
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
head to
policygenius.com.com to get started
right now if you're dumb like me it's
p-o-l-i-c-y
genius g-e-n-i-u-s
dot com policy genius when it comes to
insurance
it's nice to get it right
um all right last one oh look who's here
everybody it's all zip
you know
can i take off my reading glasses for a
second just talk to you guys one-on-one
you know there are some things in life
that i like to pick out myself
so
i know i've got
the one
that's best for me
like cuts of steaks mattresses bottles
of wine
or choose an example of your own
i don't know who you're gonna marry
what if you did the same thing for
hiring what if you took it that
seriously choose your ideal candidate
before they even apply
that's where how long before they start
doing a psychological background on some
people scale 1 to 10 how would you rate
your childhood uh that's where zip
back
curtis invite to apply comes in it gives
you
as the hiring manager the power to pick
your favorites from top candidates and
right now you can try it for free
at zip
dot com slash burr yeah rather than
having a bunch of yahoos coming in you
get to sift through like a dating app so
only people you're interested in come
your way how does invite to apply work
well
when you post a job
they spend the
they send you the most qualified people
for your job then you can easily review
the candidates invite your top choices
look at the answer
to apply
for your job that's the old school way
of hiring lauren webbs
svp senior vice president of talent
acquisitions for
mendula
mendula health
mendola
isn't that a part of your brain
the upper mendula
uh raves about
zip recruiters invite to apply she says
i love that fee i love that feature
because we have a much higher
follow-through rate if i invite
candidates it's easy for me
and it's easy for them in fact according
to zipper
recruiters internal data
jobs where employers use zip
returns invite to apply get on average
two and a half times more candidates
which helps make for a faster hiring
process
i'm not good at math i don't understand
how you have more candidates
more qualified candidates i get that
anyways don't listen to me see for
yourself just go to this exclusive web
address sip
yeah dot com slash burst spell out burp
b-u-r-r to try zip recruiter for free
that's ziprecruiter.com
the smartest way to hire
that last read was somebody starting to
say it and then falling off a balcony
and you're in the apartment below zip
the smartest way to hire sorry about
people on airplanes
oh my god
i just yelled like that you're wearing
these [ __ ] headphones on an airplane
that person's knee next to you in their
hot jeans
huh just [ __ ] touching you
sweaty [ __ ] leg
sorry all right kayak recommendations as
i
mentioned oh billy freckel tits really
enjoyed uh being on the beach
so i was talking about how i um
kayaking that's something i could do at
the beach i could get into that i got a
paddle i can beat away the [ __ ]
sharks hey old chrome dome
um i heard one of the best things i ever
heard one time i was as far as chrome
goes
and the only guy ever heard say it i was
uh on one of those fan boats in the
everglades in florida
um
and one of them had we pulled up to one
because one had broken down with all
these alligators
and they were talking about the boat
how it looked good but you know it
wasn't running and this guy was smoking
a cigarette this redneck dude and he
goes well it won't
if it won't go chrome it
is what he said i think that's what he
said if it won't go chrome it or if it
won't run chrome it
and me my wife started laughing because
i was immediately thinking like yeah if
it looks like [ __ ] shine it up someone
will buy it
i don't know if that's an expression if
you live in florida
you know if you're a redneck and there's
no shame in that all right because i'm
white trash i'm white trash all [ __ ]
day long
all right
i would eat chip beef on toast tonight
tonight you know
what do you want to talk you want to
talk a dual family house you want to
talk about squirrels in the walls i'm
all over it
talk to you all day
you want to talk about a basement that
smells like it's been underwater for a
hundred years we can do this we can have
this conversation
rednecks are white trash that know how
to fix [ __ ] that's how i look at it
white trash is just [ __ ] they're just
trash you're like yeah just blowing down
the street oh god this [ __ ] guy right
um hey old chrome dome i heard you
looking heard you're looking at kayaks
check out hobby
hobie i guess is how you say it oh like
the hobie baker award hobie kayaks
they're expensive dude i don't want to
be on some cheap hunk of [ __ ] out there
but in addition to paddling
propulsion they also have
foot pedal drives where you just pedal
yourself where you want to go you'll be
able to fit your little ones
on there with you too wait a minute and
he's got a link
i don't live anywhere near the water and
i'm gonna i'm thinking of buying this
would you look at those
oh my god how okay these are all
beautiful
how expensive are they
all right let's click on one
let's go with the nice [ __ ] we'll go
with the neon yellow
take a test ride on this thing
1500 bucks
i'd [ __ ] buy one of those and i would
[ __ ] buy one of those of course i got
to live in a state with no [ __ ] water
does anybody out here go kayaking
also sounded like you mentioned the ones
people were standing on those are stand
up panel paddle boards it kind of seemed
like people use those to get out to
their boat
um or
sups uh
boat b-o-t-e makes some pretty good ones
and they even have one where you can you
can convert to a little motorized boat
slash sup stand-up
paddleboard all right
boatboard.com b-o-t-e board.com might
even get you more into fishing hope you
and your family are doing well go [ __ ]
yourself if i ever went fishing i would
catch one fish and that would be it like
i'm eating this i'm done
i'm not trying to get the biggest one
i'm not trying to get more than the guy
next to me i'm just taking what i need
all right
maybe i should do 23 and me and see if i
have a native american in me
huh bad ass would that be if i was part
of patchy
um
sharks and helicopters
deer spotted scrotum scalp jesus christ
going from marrow on that one uh i'm a
huge fan jesus are you and a gen and
generally agree with your point of view
but your most your recent rant about
shark attacks is absolutely ridiculous
first of all i hate to be well first of
all okay you insult
which i think i have a beautiful head
i'm standing by that i have a beautiful
head i take care of it i lotion it up i
laser off anything and it's unsightly
you know i keep it [ __ ] i keep it you
know i keep it shaved nice and smooth
all right so [ __ ] yourself on that one
then you tell me you're a huge fan of
mine so you brought me back and this is
an abusive relationship okay you say
something that if i wasn't such a strong
person it didn't have a little bit of
apache blood in me i would have started
crying
okay but i shook that off then you
[ __ ] draw me back in by saying i'm
you're a huge fan and then you then then
the very next dude he wasn't even the
same sentence dot dot dot
you tell me i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm talking about
well i have to tell you as the social
justice warrior who's trying to live his
best life you're probably right i have a
ridiculous fear of sharks i do i know it
is i know it's ridiculous
all right first of all i hate the beach
i hate the sand the sun the seaweed the
stupid [ __ ] jellyfish i hate the
goddamn winter and all the dumbass
people who waste their days there
the water sorry i hate the goddamn water
i was like jesus jumping seasons here i
hate the goddamn water and all the
dumbass people waste their days there
but i'm sure as [ __ ] not afraid of
sharks
all right well it doesn't sound like you
go anywhere near him
your whole bit about being attacked by a
shark is no different than some [ __ ]
crying about the dangers of helicopters
uh
there there's way more helicopter
crashes per year
than shark attacks by the way
okay fair enough i've never understood
doing that
going from one variable to another
because it isn't just as simple as that
i would say there's way more people
now there isn't way more people flying
helicopters
you know what maybe that's a good one
maybe that is a good one i have no idea
but all i know is the helicopter is not
trying to kill me
i kind of have to put in some work to
make it kill me but i guess sharks are
the same way if you have a phobia of
sharks then man up and own that [ __ ]
admit it's an irrational
and own the phobia stop making excuses
you sound like a like a little [ __ ]
love the podcast and go [ __ ] yourself
listen
i don't know what me being afraid of
sharks just [ __ ] triggered in you
but i i don't i think what the [ __ ] was
that what are you some [ __ ] football
coach from the 70s
i've always said that i'm [ __ ]
terrified of him and there's no [ __ ]
way i'm going i'm allowed to have a fear
all right you know what you sound like
you sound like somebody needs to go home
and go hug his dad go [ __ ] yourself
[ __ ] [ __ ] i fly helicopters
all right
i got the balls to do that but because
you got the balls to do that doesn't
mean i go [ __ ] cave diving
i like swimming i like just i like the
same way i fly is the same way i swim i
try to minimize the risk i try to put
the odds in my favor
that's what i do
okay that's just what i do there's some
people if they're going to deep fry a
turkey they're going to do it on their
deck
they're going to do it on their wooden
deck and they're going to just yeah you
know i could [ __ ] you know i don't
think anybody's going to tip it over
and they take that risk and there's
other people they do in the driveway
with the fire extinguisher there that
that's how i am
that's how i am okay
and uh
what is stop making excuses that all
that whole thing fascinated that took me
way back in my life you have a phobia of
sharks
that man up and own that [ __ ] i i feel
like i am by saying how much i have it
uh how afraid i am in the ocean i
literally say i'm terrified of the ocean
i think i've said that
a thousand times in this pocket admit
it's irrational
in other words agree with you
and own the phobia listen it's not
irrational the level that i have is is
probably irrational the odds of it
happening
okay
yes absolutely
i'll admit to that but it's not
irrational
it's not something to not be concerned
of
uh
stop making excuses you sound like a
little [ __ ]
well listen to the tough guy who never
goes to the [ __ ] beach or goes in the
goddamn water jesus christ i wish i was
dude jesus whatever all right god bless
you sir i agree with everything you say
i'll try to be less for [ __ ] there we
go
all right next invasion
dear billy from the future
uh what country do you think the u.s
and its corporate allies invade next
oh i like this question i think it's ten
to one i think ten to one it's in the
middle east it might seem hacky but i
just don't see the troops rolling in to
anywhere else
next up i'd say northern africa and then
south america is a close third i will
tell you this i like your picks
but i would actually say
that i would say south america is next
and we're going to invade lush land
because water fresh water is going to be
the next oil
that they're going to go after
um
i think that eventually hopefully sooner
rather than later people are going to
realize
that um
well i don't know you'd have to the
thing about it is we we've been slaves
to the oil companies and the banks
forever so
you know you're going back to like
i mean that is just pure evil
um the amount of people that both of
those
lines of businesses
have
killed over the years i mean i can't
imagine
where the numbers at it has to be in the
[ __ ] hundreds of millions
that people have
that those two basic jobs have killed
and the desire for making money and the
desire for um
gaining control of oil getting oil and
selling oil and all that the amount of
people that have died innocent people is
just off the charts but they have a ton
of [ __ ] money
so i like
you know
i like your pick
about the middle east we're already
there so it's very easy to demonize
another country there
um
northern africa
i don't know i think it's gonna be south
america
um
yeah
but i really love
your question and the fun way you put
the evil [ __ ] that we've been doing
uh in a way
it's [ __ ] bananas
it's [ __ ] bananas and by the way us
leaving afghanistan i mean
am i out of my mind does that not look
like a frame
for frame
reenactment of us leaving vietnam
like if you literally show us leaving
afghanistan and play jimi hendrix hey
joe
or some doors or something like that
it's the exact same event
all over again
um
i don't know for the life of me i've
said it forever i do not understand
how
war is still legal i just don't get it
um i don't give a sh i don't understand
why people give a [ __ ] so much about
money
you know once you have enough why do you
want more i don't understand that i just
don't get any of that i just wish that
these [ __ ]
[ __ ] people would stand up to these
suits
they're literally people in suits just
stand up to them tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves and go in a different
direction
and maybe we could [ __ ] help people
i don't know
i don't know all right that's sorry that
was old billy bergenstock there all
right australia
yo billy of the north
and aussie here writing in
it's getting crazy mate our lockdowns
are severely worse than almost all of
the world despite things getting better
the irrational rule of this shitty
governance is getting worse
you may have seen videos going around of
kids being taken from parents because of
a positive covet test everyone is
outraged but there is a great divide
between people in our country sounds
familiar even the ones that think it is
wrong will still defend the fact that
it's being done which is totally
backward if you ask me poor kids got to
sleep somewhere strange with people in
hazmat suits delivering them food on a
tray i'm sure that won't cause any
life-lasting trauma
and if that doesn't twist your [ __ ]
check out the dog shelter where the cops
went in and shot all the dogs by order
of the city
i don't want to watch that bjork's shire
council in the state
states northwest killed the dogs to
prevent volunteers at a cobar based
animal shelter from traveling to pick up
the animals last week
according to council
watchdog
the office of local government all right
as an american just seeing how [ __ ] up
you guys are i hate to say this in a
selfish way made me feel a little bit
better
um yeah i mean there's no solution to
the covet thing i mean
it's like people are going to do
whatever the [ __ ] they want to do
um
the kids are suffering and the reason
why they're suffering is because
everybody thinks they know the solution
even though they don't have a medical
degree i've been saying this from the
beginning if we all just did the same
thing if we're all doing the same thing
it would be so much easier
to predict this thing but if you know
half the people are running this way and
the other half are running 180 degrees
in the other different direction it's
like what we keep doing it's like
there's a house on fire we keep putting
out half the house and then moving in
and then getting surprised that it gets
engulfed in flames again
um
what we're gonna have to do is what
we've never done ever is all get
together and work
and respect each other and all
pull in the same direction which is
you know
we're failing this test miserably
and then when we try to get people and
i've been guilty of this
too of uh
we try to get people to come to our way
of thinking is we then insult them like
hey [ __ ] head why don't you [ __ ] get
your head out here at like who's
listening after hey [ __ ] it i've been
guilty of that too
uh
not to mention sounding like a [ __ ]
about my shark stuff
you know what i so wish i didn't read
that email
i wish i kept that to myself and i would
have just kept ramping up how much i'm
afraid of sharks just just the level
of anger in that email i loved because i
relate to it so much um yeah let me
focus
let me focus on this guy in this [ __ ] i
do like i flipped out about not being
able to find a spatula the other day in
the kitchen i was like wait a minute
what am i really mad at
and i figured it out and i dealt with it
and then looking back at yelling about a
spatula it just seemed so [ __ ]
ridiculous to me
um or maybe i didn't understand the tone
of it that could have been that anyway
overrated underrated everybody
underrated reading a book on the beach
jesus that seemed like it would hurt
your eyes
you know
sit there with the sun glaring down on
the book
you must have some really nice
sunglasses uh reading a book on the
beach i heard you talk about oh my god
sitting in the sun reading
that that i would i would rather get
waterboarded
i heard you talk about your ocean state
i love to read but never do and the only
place i can do i can is on the beach i
get that you have pigment you know and
you have a brain so that must be amazing
that sounds great so i'm happy for you
uh it's the only time i ever finished a
book in my adult life
if i don't finish i have to wait till
the next summer till i'm on the beach to
even finish
it's really interesting
um
my thing you know underrated being at
the beach after the sun is down
in in
twilight
that is the best for me that is the best
going for a nice swim then you know
trying to block out that woman who
[ __ ]
swam at the beginning of [ __ ] jaws
you know that's what i think about i get
really really scared
god i get scared goosebumps
i'm just trying to get this guy to yell
at his [ __ ] laptop right now uh
overrated but i do think about that
overrated libraries for studying being
surrounded by people who are all
pretending to not look around and do
work can be tough
college libraries aren't as bad because
they have chairs spread out all around
in weird places you know what i just
read that and i didn't hear a word i
just said because i was really thinking
about this guy saying how irrational my
fear was and dude when i tell you i went
to go walk out on that sandbar
that went an eighth of a mile out and
when i got 30 feet offshore like i
literally wanted to keep walking and
couldn't and i just turned back around i
was just like i just i can't
it's it's it it's too big the [ __ ]
thing is just too [ __ ] big
i can't handle it
i'm a small town pool guy
um over i want to read stories about
people facing their fears and then dying
let's see if that happens because that's
[ __ ] like you get out there and face
your fear you [ __ ] [ __ ] imagine if i
went out there and got eaten by a shark
that would be so funny you guys couldn't
even get you couldn't even get
you'd be a little sad i'd like to think
but i think the comedy
would just outweigh it
so then the guy goes get over your
[ __ ] fear
and the [ __ ] orange cup gets eaten by
a shark
you guys been laughing forever
people who
faced their fears
and then died
how do you spell died
d-i-e-d doesn't look right these famous
figures suffer from unique phobias
amazing leaders who once had stage
fright seven seven steps to overcoming
your fear of death
necrophobia i thought this had
necrophilia
seven steps to overcome your necrophilia
start with [ __ ] people who are
sleeping please get their consent first
all right
um
okay here we go
this is these famous figures suffered
from unique phobias
all right
kings and presidents have always been
keen to be seen as wise here's a big
long intros [ __ ] all of that okay 19
hands
christian anderson
hans
hans christian andersen what does this
guy do was he was he a sailor do you
write a book
the danish writer hans
christian anderson had a vivid
imagination and obsessive thoughts of
being buried alive
dominated his later years
oh what if i'm still alive well then he
should have killed himself
uh had a color
don't ever have me work suicide hotline
had a colorful imagination over the
course of his prolific career i'll be
the judge of that
sorry uh he wrote a number of children's
classics including the emperor's new
clothes
the ugly duckling and of course
the little mermaid i didn't know he
wrote the little mermaid
how did disney get the rights to that
he probably probably told his
next-to-kin if you don't sell us that
the rights to the little mermaid we will
bury you alive
uh however
his ripe imagination and active mind was
often a curse as well as a blessing
anderson had a number of fears not the
least
the fear of being buried alive he even
took active measures to ensure that he
would never endure his
this fate worth
worth
worse than death somebody wrote worth
than death
is it possible to write in a lisp worth
worth and death
uh not that such a fear was completely
irrational at the very least it was
certainly understandable given the time
the victorian era was undoubtedly the
golden age
of
phobia fear of the grave
the popular press regularly printing
sensational almost certainly inaccurate
tales of people waking up waking up in a
coffin six feet under oh jesus star
magazine
fdr was so terrified terrified of fires
he refused to lock the doors of his
white house bedroom
he used to do fireside chats
to america
america
adolf hitler
after the war hitler's own dentist
revealed
what a bad patient the dictator was
oh my god
he killed six million people and he had
bad breath
i mean what jesus how the [ __ ] did this
guy get a following
adolf [ __ ] mouth hitler
wants to take over the world
screaming up there spitting adolf hitler
liked to portray himself as a superman
but he had a deep rooted phobia of
dentists which may explain why he had
such terrible oral hygiene oh my god
people just
maybe that's why they did the hitler
they were trying to block his [ __ ]
[Music]
when ss officer john
was captured by soviet forces at the end
of the second war they were keen to
interrogate him after all he had served
as the permanent personal dentist to
several high-ranking nazis once more it
also emerged that he had been the
dentist of adolf hitler too upon being
questioned
black was only too happy to condemn his
former patient but rather than
criticizing hitler for his crimes
against humanity in wars of aggression
the dentist simply revealed him to have
been a terrible patient furthermore he
made it clear for all his monstrosity
hitler had an acute fear of the dentist
chair
well it was the 1940s i mean jesus
christ according to dr
hitler suffered from terrible bad breath
abscesses and gum disease yuck
jesus christ all right let's read one
more here
oh this [ __ ] weirdo salvador dali
this guy jesus christ
an abusive relationship with his
girlfriend god she treated him like [ __ ]
was it was terrified of insects and had
a particular phobia of grasshoppers
a fear that used to influence his work
grasshoppers
in his day salvador dali was one of the
most celebrated we know what the [ __ ] he
did the clock's melting we get it but
the printer and sculptor was not always
so popular as a child growing up in
catalonia he was bullied by boys his own
age here we go this is how we started
painting as well as calling him names
they would throw grasshoppers at him
this had a profound and long lasting
effect
how fast were these bullies they're just
catching grasshoppers they go to the pet
store
augustus caesar
jesus christ i mean how far back you're
gonna go
augustus caesar was worried his [ __ ]
loincloth was gonna [ __ ] come flying
up when he was fighting a tiger all
right overrated libraries for studying
being surrounded by people who are all
pretending to not look around and do
work can be tough
uh
college libraries aren't as bad because
they have chairs spread out all around
in weird places i don't understand that
sentence being surrounded by people who
are all pretending to not look around
and do work can be tough
oh that's overrated oh oh overrated
college libraries aren't as bad because
they have chairs spread out
all around in weird places
yeah the library
the college library that's that's like
going to the movies
you know there's always going to be
somebody behind you talking giggling and
just being a douche
so i get that um
i get that going to the library for
studying that's when you got to have the
headphones on
the bose noise canceling headphones
um
which by the way you know i have a pair
of those that i've had forever and they
the the
inside foamy part the part that the
squishy part that goes against your ears
kept coming off and somebody told me to
super glue it on so i did
and now the the spongy part is all worn
out so a buddy of mine bought me the
replacements because i didn't know you
could get a replacement for those things
that's the great thing about bows is you
can
you can uh
you know same in aviation like if your
your headset
starts acting up you send it in they'll
actually repair it
so he bought the replacement ones for my
bose headset thing but i can't get the
other ones off because i use crazy glue
does anybody know how to uncr i never
even thought to google it let's see if i
can do it now
how
to un
crazy glue something
how to unsuper glue something super glue
can be removed from glass countertops
tiles and other hard surfaces with
rubbing alcohol
let's see
from
plastic
for plastic lay a damp cloth over the
glued areas
and secure it tightly
alternately soak the glue
in vegetable oil or diluted
vinegar
let it sit for a few hours
to allow the glue to moisten i'm going
to ruin my headset blot the glue
with acetones
acetones acetones or rubbing alcohol and
let this substance break down the glue
that's what i'll do i'll just try
blotting it
with alcohol all right anyways that is
the podcast everybody go red sox
go [ __ ] yourselves enjoy the next couple
of days
and uh there's no reason to be afraid of
sharks or dentists
or to kill six million people who didn't
do anything to you all right that's the
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves i'll check in
on you
on thursday